oh there's nothing in here first I was
like god damn so how's it run back again
I think we have this extremely sexy
torso
I would eat myself but perhaps another
day
look at that hairy chest omnomnom um why
should we throw it get it boy are you
[ __ ] me eat it don't eat me please
[Music]
is he doing is he busy reading my book
don't eat me don't eat me don't leave me
hi why the tour's yeah all had a hairy
shells how could he resist stay out of
the water why thank you
if oh you have got to be kidding oh
thank god happy mm sets usual no problem
360s holy [ __ ] I don't even know what
I'm doing
get up that's what she said holy [ __ ]
that was uh Nadine I jumped over him
[ __ ] the wrong direction of course
[Music]
not MLG so MLG freaking triple jump holy
[ __ ] up up up up ah come on dude alright
I'm done
I'm so [ __ ] done with this place holy
[ __ ]
[Music]
I'll thank God very nice coming using
I recognize this place and they even
left me a note when the e you'll see
blue and the lion see red one drop of
blood shall reveal the path of penis
right sounds reasonable
can we make out I stopped when I wanted
to make out what an [ __ ]
and now he continues really really
what an [ __ ] seriously though I just
want to make out
[Music]
I don't trust you
what's going here I guess
this would be their last room I play for
today ain't a lot of [ __ ] dining
halls it's locked perhaps penis dream
the whole Sookie
maybe this one
what do we have here celery that sounds
great awesome this is some creepy at all
not a water slide or something funny
let's put a cellar there holy [ __ ] is a
key there we go yeah this looks just as
bad as I was gonna say my penis but it's
not true actually
anyway it's like we have more barrels I
hate you oh hi you really hate me too
don't you
tinderbox puffle one five six five it's
hard to see I'm gonna use the barrel
thank you kind barrel uh-huh
three three five Wow holy [ __ ] did
something in it
did you do that barrel
he is doing that anyway mmm okay maybe
for up
stop rolling around it's not a freakin
come on stop it
okay so six and then to here and then
[Music]
no it will not work out this won't work
out
if that was a six it would've worked out
and I would love some more oil with
did that work six-six
one
No
no soul seven men plus
no.11
7-eleven huh too much on this side six
six or
[Music]
[ __ ]
come on - you can do this video alright
four five thirty six seven eight nine
ten and a phone call I'm so popular it's
crazy
come on I'm running out of all here I
play anywhere though that's how the
energy I am
6 6 5 5 5 too many others close already
but you know we have one 5
[Music]
I'm 11
now it's that face
11:13
nope
huh eight
10 and then 1012 [ __ ]
or if you just put it Midway I guess it
has to be somewhere I suppose you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
before
six
that's not working either okay so
nine-nine
it's supposed to be correct one two
three eight nine five seven six what
five six seven eight nine yeah it's
supposed to be right and it's not I'm
not touching that anymore that's what
she said [ __ ] it I'm gonna go
stupid [ __ ] pencils whatever I do to
them I'll never know let's see what's in
here
lots of stuff to break that's what I see
what you get for being an [ __ ] maybe
I need these by the way ice alcohol
let's toast
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] how the heck did I do
that did you see that [ __ ] stealing
alcohol what I get if that I get if that
gets stuck by nice holy [ __ ] that was
that was like top top top ten miracles
of video games right there whoa whoa
whoa whoa barrels everywhere it's you
the [ __ ] barrels who keep telling him
I knew it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh man he's so sexy why am i heading why
am I not oh I am I'm not putting out
these like you know
the same work get let's hide bandoleros
if he comes in there I'm so [ __ ]
[ __ ] like he wants my ass all I can
tell I'm talking way too much today I
can just feel it
oh crap this is not look at him this
let's go no no no thank God thank God oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I can't believe you
didn't see me
such an [ __ ]
you seem like the tip of his head
[Music]
yeah he didn't even know let's slip the
son of a [ __ ] let's go
I said go not get stuck stupid Danielle
barrels blocking my way again oh god I
hate you guys so much open the door come
on dude
uh-huh puzzle with or no visible there
must be enough
man oh man oh man oh man oh man oh man
oh man oh man oh [ __ ] oh crap he's right
there oh [ __ ] don't tell me it's gone
past this door
holy [ __ ] is
just say quiet don't talk
a sneak eyes come back in holy [ __ ]
but I've been in these rooms
happy place happy place beauty happy
place happy place happy place happy
place happy place happy place why the
[ __ ] did he oh happy place unicorns and
rainbows
and stuff I'm out of here
holy [ __ ]
415 penis oh man
ah no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no close it close it close
it close it close it close it
no problem what am i doing No No please
wait I wants to call it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you see later bye bye ha this is so
funny having so much fun happy place
happy place happy place happy place how
the [ __ ] did you know I was in the
closet
we [ __ ] penis Dease Winky
I think we got what we came for
I'm out of here
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's just take a [ __ ] do
anything
let this up
[Music]
it's gotta be another what the [ __ ]
barrels scare the [ __ ] out of me this
puzzle is [ __ ] correct look at that
four [ __ ] five six plus three
it's nine in both [ __ ] penises buting
that oh [ __ ] am I still there isn't he
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is he doing there oh it's
a barrel again Jim is making me [ __ ]
paranoid
I think you left though
yeah stupid son-of-a-bitch
stupid sexy son-of-a-bitch I gotta give
them that
uh-huh but it's still that door that I
solved the [ __ ] puzzle for but no I'm
gonna end it here I guess this is like
three parts I recorded a holy [ __ ] I'm
sweating like a [ __ ] I was gonna
play fatal frame but I'm not very good
at emulators and it Romsey slow-mo when
I play it it's like I'm so I'm gonna try
to fix that I have a pretty good
computer search should be able to run
man but we're gonna end this with making
out with ah he still doesn't want to
make out that [ __ ] [ __ ] one day
mister I got to make out with you